welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Anthony Mason with Gayle King and Tony
to copal Democrats are working to
advance gun bills in Congress in an
effort to pressure Republicans and the
White House in the wake of several
deadly mass shootings it's a personal
issue for many people even though it's
not touched by violence 42% of Americans
say there is a firearm in their home
according to a Pew Research study the
country's largest and best-known gun
rights Association the NRA is losing
board members but another lesser-known
gun organization is thriving
Omar Villafranca went to an Atlanta gun
range to meet members of the National
african-american gun Association the
largest minority gun group in the
country Philip Smith remembers the first
time he went to a gun range loaded his
9-millimeter pistol and pulled the
trigger
I felt free I had a chance to kind of
have some power in my hands Smith turned
that power into a passion and formed the
National african-american gun
Association or Naga the first chapter
was in Atlanta I didn't think I get more
than 30 people in just five years Naga
has become the largest minority gun club
in the country there are more than 75
chapters with more than 30,000 members
and over 90% of the members are black we
have folks of every walk of life black
doctors gay straight Republicans
Democrats you name it we have it
we're not monolithic and why we're all
here we have different reasons why not
join the NRA well the NRA is good for
some people that are having that
perspective our spective is for black
folks naziha Davis joined Agra to learn
how to protect herself and she's not
alone more than 60% of nagas members are
black women obviously looked at it like
I'm a Martian I mean literally if I come
in and I get ready to go into the gun
range people are looking at me like why
is she here black women don't shoot but
we shoot after black churchgoers were
targeted in Charleston in 2015 and the
recent shooting in El Paso targeting
Mexicans members say they're prepared to
defend themselves do you feel the
this political climate that white
nationalists are emboldened to go after
minority groups and you need this
protection I do I like I said even
though I generalize it's not just crime
in our communities but it's also a white
nationalist I mean I do believe they are
emboldened and yes I want to be armed I
want to I'm not going down without a
fight
so I look at it that way and so by being
able to protect ourselves by training
properly and getting our practice in and
learning how to defend ourselves at
least we will be able to fight back if
we are attacked from white supremacy
white nationalist Nagas promotes the
Second Amendment and social justice but
Smith says he's aware of the dangers of
being black and legally armed in America
he pointed to the falando Castile case
in Minnesota where Castile who was
licensed to carry a gun was shot and
killed by a police officer during a 2016
traffic stop Naga immediately condemned
the shooting while Smith points out
other prominent gun rights groups like
the National Rifle Association did not
them not speaking up says more to us
than anything are you in agreement with
that I couldn't be silent tears came out
of Minds when I heard this brother got
shot if you're an organization and once
you get black folks to back you up
that's the best way speak out when you
see injustice don't sit there silently
like you don't know what's happening
because we're a very intelligent group
of folks the group is talking about
getting political in endorsing
candidates which could make them a
political force but they're not there
yet it's something they'll discuss at
their first national conference next
year for CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca Atlanta
that video the Castile shooting is still
very very painful and difficult to watch
and I thought he raised a really good
point you know we're speaking out
against it the NRA had nothing to say at
the time when that shooting made
national news 30,000 numbers they could
be a political force I think any
coverage of Gun Owners is useful because
so many people who don't own guns which
are the majority of Americans they're
mystified by though these people are so
it's a great window into that life know
who they are